[Music]
okay i read this book back in grade
school
the title says it all dear napoleon i
know you're dead
but it's about a kid who writes letters
to napoleon bonaparte
who is of course dead the cover design
is classic 90s chapter book and shows
something the main character
is obsessed with this weird thing
napoleon seemed to always
do pose with one hand in his coat
i don't know why but that part of the
book always stuck with me
and i honestly thought everyone pictured
napoleon this way
until i asked my co-workers about it if
i were to ask you
to strike a pose like napoleon bonaparte
what would you do um
[Music]
really is this wrong almost
everyone i asked did a sort of variation
of a typical hero pose
which makes sense but once you see the
shirt thing
you can't unsee it oh wow okay
oh that's a lot more sultry than i knew
napoleon
to be yeah what stands out to you about
that i mean definitely like his hand
why is his hand in his shirt what yeah
why does he have his hand in his coat
napoleon bonaparte is one of history's
most famous figures
his many successful military campaigns
in the early 1800s
expanded the size and influence of
what's known as the first french empire
over which he ruled as emperor napoleon
is remembered as both an
influential military commander and a
ruthless power-hungry tyrant
he was depicted in dozens of portraits
and painted scenes throughout his life
and well beyond his death and an
overwhelming number of them
look just like that book cover napoleon
standing with his right hand concealed
inside his coat
the more you look at it the weirder it
is
why why it kind of seems like no matter
what napoleon was up to
gazing at charlemagne's throne rejecting
people's ideas crossing the alps riding
on a boat retreating from russia or just
hanging at home
that hand was just always jammed right
in there and i really thought everyone i
asked to do a napoleon impression
would immediately do the hand thing who
would know that
well actually a few people did isn't he
like this and then he's got his like
hand
in his jacket or something the gesture
has appeared in caricatures of napoleon
and actors portraying him over the years
watch for it in this bowling scene from
bill and ted's excellent adventure
[Music]
see
[Music]
people have speculated that napoleon's
hidden hand may have been deformed
or that he was relieving chronic stomach
pain caused by cancer
and he did eventually die of stomach
cancer but the real reason napoleon was
always painted like this
had nothing to do with organ pain or a
deformity
and everything to do with his public
image
[Music]
well it wouldn't be a vox video if we
didn't roll the clock back
concealing a hand in one's coat was a
portraiture cliche
long before napoleon was painted that
way in the early 1800s
this is george washington doing it in
1776
and mozart over a decade before that
this painting of spanish conquistador
francisco pizarro
is from 1540. the pose's documented
roots go all the way back to ancient
greece
where famed orator eskinis claimed that
restricting the movement of one hand
was the proper way to speak in public as
opposed to the more animated gesturing
of his rival
demosthenes which was apparently
unbecoming
that association of restraint as a sign
of respectability
stuck except the tunics became jackets
this 1737 british etiquette guide the
rudiments of genteel behavior
declared that keeping a hand in one's
coat was key to posturing oneself
with manly boldness tempered with
becoming modesty
the gesture became a stock pose in
portraits painted in the mid-1700s
like it was everywhere it was a popular
choice for men
and less frequently women who wanted to
visually align themselves with nobility
and for less talented portrait artists
since hands are hard to paint
[Music]
and unsurprisingly as the pose became
more and more common in paintings
its reputation cheapened that is until
one of the most powerful people in the
world
made it his trademark napoleon was
famous for many things
namely his innovative and successful
strategies in warfare
he was obsessed with gaining power at
all costs and won battle after battle
in what are now called the napoleonic
wars briefly establishing french
domination in europe
all while fostering a grandiose image
like
organizing an elaborate coronation
ceremony for himself in 1804
immortalized in this state-sanctioned
painting of the event
but outside of france he was a popular
figure for caricature
and was repeatedly portrayed as a small
man with a hot head
like in this 1803 british political
cartoon
maniac ravings or little bony in a
strong fit
which is why this famous portrait of
napoleon in his study
is significant it was done in 1812 by
his official painter
jacques louis david who also made some
of the period's most recognized
paintings
it's a departure from many previous
depictions of the conqueror
including some by david himself and
represents an effective example of
propaganda
there are key details here that tell a
story of a modest
hard-working leader the candles are
burned all the way down
and the clock shows that it's almost 4
15 in the morning
napoleon stands from his desk having
worked all night completing his
signature legislation
the napoleonic code this map on the
floor and napoleon's sword at the ready
are reminders of his successes on the
battlefield
but it's the restrained pose with
centuries of context surrounding it
that stands out crowds of people
apparently came to see the painting in
1812
and david himself wrote that the
portrait's popularity was due to the
exceedingly close resemblance to that
immortal man
in that air of benevolence and composure
a stark contrast to other contemporary
images of the ruler
napoleon didn't actually pose for this
portrait but he's quoted to have said
upon seeing it
you have understood me my dear david
this gesture of modesty and steady
leadership became a common way to depict
napoleon and stuck with him
well beyond his death in 1821 but the
pose's legacy didn't end with napoleon
the well-established portrait cliche was
also a trend in early portrait
photography
with notable sitters like karl marx and
even the celebrated inventor of
photography himself
louis aguero adopting the gesture it was
also a common appearance in portraits of
soldiers fighting in the american civil
war
concealing a hand gave the subject a
distinguished look
and helped keep them in sharp focus
during the long exposure times of early
photography
which often rendered blurred hands
[Music]
is this familiar at all to you i mean
sort of that's actually not really what
i imagined him looking like
that's what napoleon looked like if you
showed me that i wouldn't guess
it was napoleon probably because he
doesn't have the hat on it's probably
pretty telling that
almost everyone i asked to do an
impression of napoleon adopted poses
based around napoleon's supposedly short
stature and his vanity
this is my pose okay napoleon
tiny man proud chest and didn't
recognize david's depiction of napoleon
or this arguably more important one
at least in my mind
this is a photo of charlie chaplin
dressed as napoleon and it features not
one
but two portraiture cliches the hand and
waistcoat gesture
and this wicker chair it's called the
peacock chair
and like the hand gesture it shows up in
tons of photos
there's a whole history of how it became
so popular and lucky for you
estelle already made a video about it